this video is sponsored by the book
summary service
blinkist the first 100 people to use the
link in the description
will receive one free week of unlimited
access and 25
off a full membership it is a strange
moment in adolescence when you first
start to truly comprehend
the concept of where you are your
position on a solitary planet
in a vast seemingly unending space of
some strange
incomprehensibly immense thing we call
universe
around the same time we realized not
only the absurdity of this bizarre
condition
but also despite our surroundings being
so apparently massive
potentially infinite rife with other
stuff other galaxies
other planets other stars and so on
somehow
we also appear to be potentially alone
one can't help but question how this
could be the case how could we be the
only ones
with the observable universe being about
90 billion light years in diameter
roughly about 13.8 billion years old
with likely around 10 to 12 billion
years of stable conditions
containing trillions of planets with
inhabitable zones potentially suitable
for life
where it would really only have taken
one early form of life to develop and
evolve enough over just millions of
years
to have colonized an entire galaxy or
more by now
it is puzzling at the very least to
consider that despite all of this
the universe is not teeming with other
intelligent life
let alone no apparent confirmed signs at
all
the curious nature of this is what is
known as the fermi paradox
the fermi paradox essentially proposes
that it is not merely ominous and
mysterious in general that we appear to
be alone
but it is also logically and
mathematically disjointed
from what many physicists and other
experts argue
should be the case ever since and prior
to the fermi paradox being conceived
a number of theories have and continue
to form that attempt to resolve
it after all perhaps the premise of the
paradox is wrong
or perhaps it's standing on false
information or perhaps the answer
is an answer that doesn't seem like an
answer when considered through our
anthropocentric intuitions
and rather must be considered from a
more detached mode of thinking
the following are seven hypotheses that
attempt to do this
some are original or at least attempt to
be some are pre-existing
and some are combinations it should also
be noted that there is
of course the separate possibility that
we have knowingly seen other forms of
life
there have been many ufo sightings and
claims of alien encounters over the
years
and more recently there have been even
more intriguing sightings confirmed by
the pentagon
and other military and government
officials however insofar as anyone
knows anyone knows for sure
all sightings are as best as we can tell
unclear
and so let's grant that we have not seen
any other life forms
and even if we have the question still
remains
why are they still so infrequent and
unobvious
why is the universe not densely packed
with life some galactic or intergalactic
colonies and civilizations
why haven't there been more conclusive
visitations or attempts to communicate
why is the night sky not lit with the
cosmic city instead of lifeless stars
hypothesis one the fishbowl hypothesis
an obvious question that arises when
considering the possibility of a first
contact
with an extraterrestrial life form is
what could we do
if we did could we communicate with them
in any meaningful way
why should we assume so right now there
are countless species on earth that we
cannot communicate with
in any meaningful way at all no matter
how hard we try
and so even in the best of cases in
which another extraterrestrial life form
was intelligent enough to communicate in
a traditional sense
the disparity between our forms of
cognition evolutionary backgrounds and
so forth
could still be significant enough to
make it so that there is not enough
common ground to stand on
to understand each other however more
relevant to the fermi paradox here
is taking this several steps further if
it is possible if not likely
that we would not be able to communicate
with other beings is it not also
possible that
with sufficiently different biological
backgrounds physical makeups
states of nature conditions and
dimensions in time and space
and whatever else the disparity may be
so great we might not even be able to
perceive them
or perhaps we can perceive them but not
with any meaningful distinction or the
mental framework to process that in fact
we are
many of the species we cannot
communicate with on earth right now
experience this with us a goldfish in a
bowl in a child's bedroom
does not and cannot know that it is in a
human being's bedroom
in a town or city made and filled with
other human beings
it does not know that it is fed and
interacted with by a higher form of
conscious intelligent life
it does not meaningfully comprehend that
there is a human in the room with it
nor what the human is saying if they
talk to it or why they are doing
anything when they do something
the fish is confined by the upper limits
of its cognition
is it not possible that this could be
the case for us where we are like lower
animals to some other species that we
cannot see or comprehend the nature of
perhaps even in the room with us right
now
two the containment hypotheses following
a similar line of thinking
it's also possible that we are not even
in the universe in the way we think we
are
at all it might be the case not that we
are incapable of perceiving some other
nearby alien life forms
but that we are intentionally isolated
by them in some sort of structure
physical digital or otherwise
disconnected and removed from reality
outside of it
one version of this is argued for by a
hypothesis known
as the planetarium hypothesis proposed
by science fiction author
stephen baxter in 2001 which speculates
that when we look out into space
we are actually observing an artificial
or virtual rendering
created by a more advanced civilization
engineered in such a way
to give off the illusion that we are
alone this parallels with the ever
increasing popular theories
surrounding the simulation hypothesis
which argues that all of existence as we
know it
is a computer simulation engineered by
some advanced species
the forms and reasons for some sort of
contained state are endless
something as simple as entertainment or
research for other beings
or something more sinister like being
imprisoned or quarantined
or of course something else so complex
we cannot even begin to imagine
three the island hypothesis still
continuing down a similar train of
thought
it could be the case that we are not
contained in any removed artificial
structure
or thing nor are we incapable of
perceiving some other nearby alien life
forms around us
but rather we are left alone in space on
purpose
if there was an island in the middle of
the ocean that if any humans went
anywhere near it they would inevitably
and horribly be infected by whatever
species lived on it
we would all avoid it likewise if there
was a species that lived on the island
that was capable of outmatching and
killing large quantities of humans
or requiring humans to kill all of them
in defense we would also avoid it
perhaps it is the case that to other
more advanced life forms
we are that species and that island is
earth
another existing iteration of this is
the hypothesis known as the zoo
hypothesis
which suggests that we could be
contained in some sort of cosmic
wilderness preserve or
zoo protected by some galactic
government ordinance
intentionally left alone in order to
preserve our natural development
or perhaps similar to the containment
hypotheses we are left alone for
entertainment or research purposes
in which we are observed from a distance
this particular hypothesis category
along with some versions of the
containment hypotheses
could also explain some amount of ufo
sightings in which there are sort of
check-ins or accidental and illegal
fly-throughs
four the remote isolation hypotheses
perhaps a consequence of the universe's
size in relation to the potentially low
odds of life forming
the odds are also such that any life
that does form
is bound to be extremely spread out thus
civilizations may just never
and likely will never come in contact no
matter how smart
or relatively extended past their home
planets they become
or perhaps there are some other
civilizations who have already crossed
paths and coexist
in some sort of galactic colony or
organization but we just happened by
chance
to be one that was birthed too far out
in the remote woods of the cosmos
there might be no reason for others to
go into these cosmic woods
except for perhaps very rare
circumstances like occasional hikers in
remote sections of the woods who quickly
move on when they noticed a nest of
another species
leaving us with no way out
extending off that is number five the
predator hypotheses
taking a slightly darker turn on the
woods analogy one version of a predator
hypotheses
is known as the dark forest hypothesis
initially thought of by science fiction
writer
xi xin liu which suggests that perhaps
the reason other species don't go out
exploring into the remote areas of the
cosmos
is not because of indifference but
because they are aware of how dangerous
it
is how risky it is to let your existence
be known
haphazardly send out signals and run
about the cosmos
perhaps there is unyielding danger
lurking just around the corners
that we are not yet aware of more
specifically
perhaps there is some particular entity
or entity group
that was first to successfully evolve in
the universe or is just the most
dangerous one that has
and it now controls and monitors the
universe if this were the case it would
likely be in this species interests and
nature
to want to maintain its control and
seeing as how it would likely have
needed to develop very aggressive
and powerful abilities to make it into
such a spot it would likely possess
unmatched aggression and power thus the
species might find it both essential and
easy
to destroy any life that it determines
has developed enough to be a potential
threat
which we have just not reached yet this
would then eliminate all new incoming
intelligent life
rendering the cosmos apparently desolate
while this predator generally maintains
stealthy concealment alternatively
perhaps it's the exact opposite in
number six what we'll call
the evolutionary revolution hypotheses
it is also possible that the more
intelligent a species gets
the more passive and less interested in
colonization or outward physical
activity it becomes
if a species is evolved enough
technologically or otherwise
it is reasonable to assume a higher
likeliness that such a species has
developed a high degree of efficiency
and effectiveness and thus has an
abundance of available time
and resources this could then reduce if
not entirely eliminate
the majority of its competitive
tendencies need or desire for violence
unethical and deceitful behaviors
interest in broader physical ownership
and perhaps desire as a whole this could
then lead to a number of outcomes
one perhaps being something that might
appear to us to be a sort of reversal of
evolution
in which the life form as it continues
forward in time and space
and becomes more intelligent its efforts
and behaviors appear to return to that
of complete passivity like an amoeba or
paramecium
or gas-like substance there's no obvious
reason to assume that the ultimate path
of evolution
is a straight line forward in any
particular direction
it very well could be more of a loop if
this were true
this would then mean that all life once
it becomes theoretically smart and
capable enough to reach other beings
it doesn't because it simply doesn't
care to
another potential form of an
evolutionary revolution that fits with
our more traditional assumptions of
evolution would be a case in which all
intelligent species
realize at a certain point of their
advancement that the outside physical
universe
is of lesser value and interest than
artificial states of existence
that they can create through technology
this is suggested by the transcension
hypothesis
created by futurist john smart where the
endgame of all intelligent life
is inevitable self-isolation into
something like a supercomputer
megastructure
like a dyson sphere a theoretical
technology structure that wraps around
and is fueled by an entire star in the
same way a human right now may choose to
stay at home
and watch tv play video games or use
their computer or
phone as opposed to going out into the
physical world this could be the case
time some unfathomable multiple
across entire civilizations of higher
intelligent life forms
thus also in this case any species that
was technologically capable of reaching
out into the universe
would just never want to last in this
category is what we'll call
the self-extinction hypothesis in this
case
once intelligent beings reach a certain
level of higher awareness
they inevitably and inescapably realize
that sentient existence
is fundamentally negative and thus
determine it unethical to continue
birthing more of themselves
all species in this case would then
eventually universally cease
reproduction
or terminate by some other means until
they run themselves out
and never extend much past their home
planets
last on the list is number seven what is
known as the rare earth hypothesis
ultimately the conclusion of this
hypothesis is that the fermi paradox
isn't really that paradoxical the math
might simply suggest that once one
accounts for all the variables
and all the things that need to go
exactly right in exactly the right order
for a long enough stretch of time
without any major break in the chain
life forming especially intelligent
conscious life
is simply very very unlikely to exist
and so it would then make perfect sense
that it doesn't and that we appear to be
alone
because we are we could simply be the
firstborn child of the universe
or perhaps we could be one of the only
surviving children
after all more than 99 of all species
that have ever lived on earth
have died out we are currently of that
one percent
one could apply those same odds to life
in the cosmos where almost all life dies
out and only one percent survives
at least this far and we might currently
be the one percent of that one percent
destined to hit a layer of zero percent
life might just be extremely rare to
start
and it might just get increasingly rare
the longer it sticks around
of course any of these in other
unmentioned hypotheses
could be combined with each other in
various ways and also of course
it could be none and something else
entirely
if you've ever explored this subject
you've almost certainly heard the arthur
c
clarke quote two possibilities exist
either we are alone in the universe
or we are not both are equally
terrifying
it's almost a cliche at this point but
this quote really deserves its frequent
usage
it so powerfully and succinctly
summarizes the crux of this issue
our condition in the cosmos there may be
a way out of the fermi paradox
there may be an explanation one way or
the other but there is no way out
of the terror and wonder that all
solutions leave us with
no matter what the case whether we are
alone or not
to ponder such terrifying yet
awe-inspiring possibilities
to knowingly carry the faberge egg of
existence through the chaotic mysterious
turbulence of the cosmos
it's perhaps insofar as we can tell for
now
a once in a universe opportunity
this video was sponsored by blinkist
given what we can suppose is true about
the universe assuming we are not in some
simulation
or contained state even in its basic
physical form
the universe is an utterly perplexing
place how did it even begin in the first
place
most scientists agree that it was
through the big bang but how did this
occur
and why his time appeared as a function
of this seemingly only going forward
confining everything within it all of
this and more
are discussed in stephen hawking's book
a brief history of time
which you can find a brief summary of
and save some of your time while you
still have it
using the book summary app blinkist
perhaps you're interested in learning
about these sorts of questions
but don't have the initial interest to
read the full 250 page book
and or perhaps this is the case for
other books by condensing complete books
down
into around 15-minute summaries blinkist
allows you to explore topics and books
more easily and conveniently without
sacrificing much additional time
this also allows you to better determine
which books you are interested in
reading in full
before spending the time to do so the
blinkist summaries can either be read or
listened to
and can be accessed even while you're
offline and better yet
blinkist now also has complete
audiobooks of select titles as well as
podcast summaries from popular podcasts
so you can dive completely into the
books and topics you want to
all in the same place blinkist has 27
categories
with thousands of non-fiction titles to
choose from and if your interests fall
more in the realm of philosophy
blankist has great titles like critique
of pure reason by immanuel kant
man search for meaning by viktor frankl
as well as many more and many other
subjects
the first 100 people to use the link in
the description will receive one free
week of unlimited access
as well as 25 off a full membership the
free 7-day trial can be cancelled at any
time within the trial period
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
you